the interview has sent shock waves
around the world in the u.s alone more
than 17 million viewers tuned in to cbs
last night
who did this interview help the internet
has been flooded with so many memes and
unsurprisingly several uk tabloids have
obliterated megan and harry online the
daily mail's pierce morgan calls the
interview quote
nauseating and a win-a-thon i'm sorry i
don't believe a word she says meghan
markle
harry and megan are very polarizing here
in in the uk
and uh the tabloids i think they're
going to go after them
so much more after this interview my
biggest concern was history repeating
itself
when i'm talking about history opinion
itself i'm talking about my my mother
and prince harry says if it wasn't for
his mother the late princess diana
they wouldn't have been able to leave my
family literally cut me off financially
and i have to wait hold up wait a minute
your family cut you off yeah in the
first half the first quarter of 2020
but i've got what my mum left me and
without that we would not have been able
to do this
how much did diana leave to him we
believe that harry's
pot is now over 10 million pounds up
until this point
harry had had no need to dip in to the
money
that his mother had left him because his
father was financing his lifestyle
you